[Musique]
puis-je vous présenter ma nouvelle
épouse colette les années folles sont
terminées alors au contraire elles
viennent tout juste de commencer
je vais l'épouser l'entrepreneur
littéraire tu as épousé une fille de la
campagne sans le sou nous sommes au bout
et le chou willy est une marque
j'ai pris d'énormes risques et ce n'est
toujours pas d'argent il faut augmenter
la production tout matures tu pourrais
écrire mes histoires d'écolière oui ça
pourrait être le prochain roman de willy
est ce que vous écrivez aussi pour lui
oui il n'a pas tardé à faire de vous un
de ses fantômes
je m'appelle claudine chapite montigny
probablement que je ne mourrai pas
c'est magnifique jamais je l'avais vu
des livres sans volé des étagères avec
une telle rapidité
ils sont achetés par des jeunes femmes a
vraiment toujours aussi subtil lui
compte bien faire de claudine la fille
la plus populaire du monde entier j'ai
l'impression que mobilis est inspiré de
vos histoires d'écolière oui j'ai été si
j'ose dire mis à contribution
nous avons enfin succès et tu insinue
que ce n'est pas moi qui en suis
l'auteur les gens aiment les ragots ici
je comprends leur mentalité patois jules
est assez bien comprises pour écrire un
livre en ce sens c'est partout pareil tu
as fait une chose importante
toutes ces jeunes filles qui leur a
donné une voix tu devrait assumer que
c'est toi il te faisait la cour
ta jalousie n'a pas sa place ne pourquoi
c'est sa femme qui m'intéressait on a de
la dynamite entre les mains elle
pourrait nous exploser au visage
depuis quand on considère tu qu'un
scandale est une mauvaise chose or comme
c'est curieux
le patronyme de coeur se divise en trois
je dois m'habituer au mariage peut-être
que ton mariage devrait s'habituer à toi
nous implore d'en écrire de nouveau dû
refuse d'écrire un autre claudine de
sculptures perdu la tête nous pour
attendre et ce que tu es
détruisez les jeux télé au feu
quand tu m'as trouvé je ne connaissais
rien
tu m'as façonnés selon ses propres
désirs
[Musique]
et tu as cru que je me mens cyprès
jamais
mais tu t'es trompé
la main qui tient la plume qui écrit
l'histoire